[Music]
this week on fyi the latest on the war
in ukraine and those trying to escape
the fighting
[Music]
and i'll be meeting ukrainian refugees
who have arrived here in the uk
and investigating why the war could lead
to a food crisis for all of us
[Music]
this is fyi your weekly news show and as
the war continues in ukraine we've been
hearing a lot about the city of mariopol
but what is actually going on there well
we've been investigating
mario paul was one of the first cities
to be attacked by the russian army back
in february when president putin ordered
the invasion of ukraine
the ukrainian army fought back but after
almost two months of fighting and
bombing the russian army took control of
mario paul
and now the ukrainian president vladimir
zelinsky says the city has been
completely destroyed
russia's actions in mario paul have been
condemned by world leaders for attacking
places like hospitals and buildings
where civilians have been taking shelter
finally russia agreed to have plans so
civilians could be evacuated from the
city to safety families who were taking
shelter in a steel factory with very
little food and water were taken to
neighboring towns and villages
it is thought that around a hundred
thousand people are still in mariopol
[Music]
millions of ukrainians have fled to
neighbouring countries since the war
began but our government has been
criticized for being too slow to like
ukrainian refugees into britain
scarlet's with a family who've just
arrived hi scarlet
hi braden up to 7 000 refugees have
signed up to come and live here in
taunton but there's nowhere near that
number here yet
it may not be home but more and more
ukrainian refugees are starting a new
life in british towns like this one i'm
about to meet evelina and her family to
see how they're settling in
england is very beautiful country and
people very kind
yeah we feel
very safe what was the journey from
ukraine to the uk like it's a very long
um road when we go to the
front friend
yeah we need to um wait for visa like
one
week the uk government promised to give
hundreds of thousands of people shelter
in this country
with lots of families like julie
offering a place to stay in their homes
so how did you all meet
well i posted on facebook um that we
were willing to host a family and then
um olga happened to go onto facebook
about 15 minutes later yeah and it was
that quick the same day we go from
ukraine you left the same day yeah
really
reaching the uk is not just about being
safe and having a place to stay
evelina's brother and sister have
already started school they very like it
they are happy to see
school yeah
they find friends yeah but there's been
a lot of criticism of the british
government that the rules can make it a
long and difficult process for
ukrainians to get into the uk
and there are still tens of thousands of
people waiting to hear if they'll be
allowed into the country
okay so this room yeah
wow it's decorated so nicely arthur and
his family are all set up to welcome
ukrainian refugees into their home but
after connecting with a family over a
month ago they're still waiting for them
to arrive and then in here
more clothes oh there's some there's a
coat and some shoes you've got
everything they're going to need haven't
you yeah and the family that asked the
hopes will move in are stuck in
temporary accommodation in ukraine
waiting to hear if the uk authorities
will let them in why did you want to
take in a family
because i thought we could help them a
lot and also if we were in their shoes
like we wouldn't want to be in ukraine
would we you know you'd want your help a
few of them so it's really great that
you're opening your home to them
hello what would you like for us
i see that your brother's in here having
loads of fun but as we were filming news
reached our third that the family had
finally got their visas to come live in
the uk what are you looking forward to
the most having
someone else in the house would be
more fun because it's just like me and
my little brother
[Music]
thanks scarlett good to end up some
positive news there and at fyr we always
like to hear what you think on the big
issues so i headed to west acre middle
school to meet their fy news club
members to get their shout on the war in
ukraine
[Music]
so we know about the terrible situations
that are going on in ukraine at the
moment but how does that make you guys
feel and how are you coping with them
feelings having family close to close to
ukraine um and sharing a border with
belarus it's quite scary and knowing
that they could be in danger but i try
to take time to call them every day and
check how they are and how they're
feeling so what do you think you know
schools and children can do to welcome
in new refugees
i think that we should welcome them with
open arms and give them supplies as in
ukraine they might struggle with
supplies in school we collect food for
food banks we could do the same
a similar thing for people in ukraine
learning the ukrainian language a lesson
so then if there were to be a ukrainian
refugee who got transported here then he
would feel more welcome so compared to
other european countries do you think
that our country the uk is doing enough
to help ukrainian refugees so i think we
are doing enough but other countries
have the available space to do more
i think we're doing
a good job but i think we could invite
more refugees in so for people who are
still in ukraine what do you think we
could do to support them there are lots
of places that we can like donate stuff
to them like food blankets and even like
toys for children to make them feel safe
so that they're not so scared we could
try writing letters to send to ukrainian
children to try and like help them and
make them feel better about what's
happening well thank you very much guys
um that was you know really really good
answers there and thank you for joining
me he was ace
if you want to have your shout on fyi
then why not get your teacher to set up
an fyi news club at your school or just
do it with your mates just head to our
webpage first.news forward slash fyi
members are given free resources to set
up their own club to watch and discuss
the programme and you could even get the
chance to report on your own stories
here on fyi one of the big issues we've
been looking into on fyi is why there's
a world food crisis and how the war in
ukraine affects that don't get it don't
worry here's more info for you
most of us take it for granted that when
we're hungry all we need to do is open
the fridge
[Music]
hmm
okay well if it's like this one then all
we need to do is
hop to the supermarket
but imagine for a moment that there is
no supermarket
and the crops that your family relies on
have failed
for more than 768 million people around
the world
finding enough food to eat is a real
problem
and it's a crisis that seems to be
getting worse
so why are so many people going hungry
well i've been looking into this and i
found out that there are three main
reasons why food is in short supply
[Music]
the first is conflict
in countries where there is fighting
intention
it can be really difficult to get hold
of fresh and healthy food
and people often have to keep moving to
escape the violence
in the case of russia's invasion of
ukraine we rely on both of those
countries for a lot of our wheat and
bali so experts are warning the conflict
could create a global shortage
then there's poverty
the cost of food has been going up and
not all families can afford to feed
themselves properly
and i'm not just talking about
developing countries
in the uk a record number of families
have had to rely on food banks
and finally there's extreme weather
caused by the climate crisis
like floods and droughts
this can cause crops to be wiped out
sometimes all three of these things can
happen at once and that's what's
happened in some of the worst affected
countries
with the situation really bad in
afghanistan
yemen
the democratic republic of congo and
south sudan
you may have seen upsetting pictures on
the news from countries where people
don't have enough food to eat and the
water isn't clean enough to drink
sadly according to the united nations
more than 25 000 people die every day
because of hunger
including 10 000 children
[Music]
so what about the future can we solve
this problem well to answer that i'm
going to need an expert
and i'm joined by professor guy poppy
from the university of southampton hello
professor poppy hi scarlett hi there so
will there be enough food to go around
in the future
that's a very interesting question
scarlett
we know that there will be an extra 2
billion people on the planet by 2050 and
those two billion people will all need
the right food and do that without
harming the environment too much so it's
gonna be difficult
but there are some solutions right
yes there are the first is we currently
throw away one third of all the food
that we buy and if we can make sure that
we eat the food we buy trying to not
throw away too much food that could have
a big impact secondly we can use
technology drones can enable us to plant
things in the best place possible so we
can produce more food from the same
amount of land it's really important
that we don't expand into things like
rainforests or nature reserves and we
stick to farming on the land that's
already farmed
and thirdly
we can change our diets most experts
around the world think that we eat
probably too much meat and too much
dairy and meat and dairy consume a lot
of the world's resources what is
recommended is that we eat more fruit
and vegetables and we eat more nuts and
peas and that will provide us with a
healthy diet and by growing more of
those we'll have a healthier environment
too
well thank you for telling us about that
thank you scarlet
so there is hope for the future but
things will need to change
the important thing is we can all play
our part right now by supporting
charities who are helping to feed people
who are going hungry
and by trying to cut out the amount of
food we throw away
we're also being asked to try and grow
our own food at home
[Music]
hmm not bad
[Applause]
the world can be a complicated place
can't it so for more explainers on big
issues like racism bullying and the war
in ukraine just head to our webpage
first dot news fyi
nice one scarlett now are your fake new
spotting skills up to scratch
apparently a face mask for cows has won
an environmental design award from
prince charles as calzbert methane a gas
that contributes to global warming the
mosque is supposed to cut down their
emissions and so will hopefully slow
down climate change but is that true
i'll let you know later
[Music]
now for a bit of hollywood in a sec i'll
be chatting to the stars of the new
movie turning red
if you haven't seen it yet turning red
is all about becoming a teenager and all
the emotions that go with it but when 13
year old melin gets a bit over emotional
she turns into a red panda alright
is everything okay
i'm a gross red monster
so i'm now joined by sandra oh and
rosalie chang hi guys how are you we're
great great thank you so rosalie you
obviously play mae lynn and she
obviously finds it quite difficult to
control her emotions but do you think
being loud and open about your feelings
can sometimes be a good thing absolutely
um throughout the film
mae gets these new emotions and she
thinks it's bad but she tries to hide it
because she's ashamed because it's her
red panda side but i think
it's okay to have these emotions it's
natural and it's also not like bad
emotions i think ultimately when you
have big emotions and highs and lows you
just especially when it's starting to
happen to you for the very first time
you will eventually learn how to try and
manage it just be kind to yourself about
them
my whole life have been perfect little
meimei
but maybe i like this new me
now did you guys take any messages away
from this film everyone takes away their
own message from this film
the red piano can represent so many
different things for me personally it
represents change and messiness because
everyone has a messy side yeah
definitely now for me throughout the
whole film i thought that the message
was really just being yourself yeah
being yourself you know for me i'd say
you know a lot of us especially during
this time
if you happen to be closer or even if
you don't have such a close relationship
with your parents this feeling of like
not being enough or not being able to
kind of please them
i think that's really real it's just a
natural thing that happens
for me as someone who is of a mom's age
it's to say
try don't be
scared about disappointing your parents
and for parents you know if they're
watching it's like just give your child
a little bit of space to as you said
what what really meant to you to be
yourself i'm a freak we love you mae
you're our girl
whoa you're you well thank you so much
for your time guys thank you
now did you guys spot this week's fake
news or fact
well the face mask designed for burping
cows is fact it cuts down the methane
gas in the cal belches which is a gas
that contributes towards global warming
it's hoped that ideas like this could
help slow down climate change
for more details on how to spot fake
news just head to our webpage well
that's it from us see you next week